تحول الان الى رام الله ومدير مكتبنا وليد
العمري وليد في مبدو ان الرد لم ليس فقط
صواريخ فقط وانما مثل ما شاهدناها الان
عمليه اطلاق النار كيف يمكن فهم
وقبل ذلك وليد نشاهد هذه الصور التي
تنقلها القناه الثانيه 10 الاسرائيليه صور
كانت لي مكان وقوع العمليه كيف يمكن فهم
دلالات وقوع عمليه كهذه في منطقه شديده
الحراسه وفي وقت اعلنت فيه اسرائيل حاله
التاهب الامنيه بعد اقتحام جنين بالامس
اولا عدد القتلى ارتفع الى سبعه وجميع من
اصيبوا عددهم اثني عشر من بينهم السبعه
القتلى حاليا اصابتهم بين حرجه وخطيره
وفقا الاسعاف الاسرائيلي والشرطه
الاسرائيليه همم ما جرى هو دليل على ان
العنف لا يجر الا العنف لانه منذ بدايه
العام عمليه القتل للفلسطينيين يمارسها
الجنود الاحتلال وكذلك المستوطنين وهي في
تصاعد وذروتها كانت في الهجوم الذي كان
على مخيم جنين امس وادى الى ما ادى اليه
من سقوط تسعه شهداء وكان هناك شهداء ايضا
في منطقه الرام الواقع الشمالي القدس
والمتاخمه بالحي الاستطلاني يعقوب واضح
بان كل الاحتياطات الامنيه همم الزجره
التي اتخذتها السلطات الاحتلال وخاصه في
المناطق التي تخضع بالكامل لسيطرتها مثل
الهيئه الاستيطاني لا يعقوب الذي يعتبر
جزءا من مدينه القدس والخاضع بالكامل
لاسياده الاسلاميه بمعنى ان لا وجود
تاثير السلطه الفلسطينيه في هذه المنطقه
تقع في قلب مثل هذا الهجوم تفاصيل الهجوم
على الحاليه تشير وحسب التقديرات
والمعلومات التي وصلت سواء نقلت نقلتها
وسائل الاعلام السعوديه عن شهود عيان او
عن مصادر الشرطه والاسعاف الاسرائيلي الى
جرعه والى ايضا ان المهاجمين يعتقدون انه
كان هناك مهاجمان واطلقان نيران من سياره
مسافره على مجموعه من الاسرائيليين في
قلبه هذا الحي الذي عاده لا يدخله العرب
لانه كسائر المناطق الاستيطانيه يخضع
للحراسه الكبيره هذا دليل كما قلت على ان
العنف لا يجر الا العنف وما فعلته اسرائيل
وقواتها منذ بدايه هذا العام وتحديدا مع
صعود هذه الحكومه وتصريحاته وزرائها الذين
ينفقون الوجود الوطني للفلسطينيين
ويتعوعدون ويهنئون كل من يقتل فلسطيني مثل
ما فعلوا مع المستوطن الذي قتل في
الفلسطينيه في منطقه
جنوبي الظاهريه الجنوبي الخليل وكذلك مع
الجنود الذين نفذوا الهجوم والعدوان الذي
وقع امس في جنين وقتل فيه ايضا مدنيون
بينهم سيدا هذا كله لا يجر الا العنف يشار
في هذا السياق الى ان هذه الذروه من
العمليات والهجمات سواء ما قام به قوات
الاحتلال والمستوطنين او ايضا هذا الهجوم
وغيره تقع في وقت
ينشط ونشط فيه كبار المسؤولين الامريكيين
كان هناك مستشار امن القومي الامريكي
واجرى مفاوض مباحثات وفي نفس الوقت كانت
قوات الاحتلال تهدم منزل وتقتل فلسطينيين
في منطقه شعفاطات والقدس وهناك ايضا اليوم
كشفه عن وجود رئيس جهاز الذي
وسرا وكل ذلك قبل وصول وزير خارجيه بلينكن